I'm Sumi somascanda correspondent with
DW news here in Washington and I'm happy
to welcome With Us online today retired
U.S army lieutenant colonel Alexander
vinman you might remember that he was
the director for European Affairs for
the U.S National Security Council under
Donald Trump and then testified in front
of Congress on Trump's attempts to
influence Ukraine into investigating Joe
Biden and his family that ultimately led
to Trump's impeachment now vinman was
born in Ukraine he is an expert on the
region and on defense and security and
we of course wanted to talk to him about
the war in Ukraine and about Europe's
role Lieutenant Colonel vinman welcome
really happy to have you with us thanks
for having me on Deutsche Valley great
to have you I want to get started with
asking you about where we stand at this
point
um in the war we're just about two
months into this war how do things look
at this point for Ukraine militarily and
also politically yeah so I think for we
could we could assess from really after
the first week or so that Ukraine was
going to exit this war as a sovereign
independent state the question really
was uh then and now what those
boundaries would look like with would
Russia Russia just didn't have the
combat power didn't assemble sufficient
forces to take over the whole country
that was clear pretty quickly but would
they be able to adapt and achieve some
military objectives uh even those are
actually frankly
um dubious I was particularly concerned
in this neck this newest phase of the
war with a much much more focused uh
operation in the East without Russia
with its experience in in multiple
contingencies military contingency
operations in Syria you know conducting
operations in um in on a much much
smaller front in Ukraine in the dunbas
in 2014 would be able to achieve some
military objectives
frankly it's not clear that they're
going to achieve all that much I think
to me just watching the last several
days of this this offensive unfold
they're having a really hard time uh
piecing together the combat power
the military force to achieve their
military objectives to secure their
supply lines and to to
really achieve an effect on this limited
front now when we say limited we should
recognize that it's still Harkey to make
alive which is 800 kilometers that is a
enormous amount of territory I was
particularly concerned about Mario Bull
and that the Russians would be able to
take that within the span of a couple
within the spread of a couple weeks they
seem to be have given up on that uh um
operation they couch it as a victory
because they've reduced uh the Ukrainian
footprint to a really small section of
the city but they haven't even managed
to do that they're looking to reposition
their forces to to achieve something and
uh that's it's unclear how far they're
gonna get but if you look at the Dyers
situation in mariopol at the moment of
people civilians and soldiers
essentially trapped in this one part of
the city how long do you think Ukrainian
forces can withstand Russia's offensive
it's interesting I think the fact is
that the Russians had assembled
somewhere in the ballpark of about 10
000 troops to take the city and uh with
this small portion of the city they're
they've now given up on that they're
withdrawing some of those forces to
achieve some of the objectives to the
North and the dunbas
um which means that they frankly they
have less forces required to hold the
city the parts of the city that they've
secured uh which means it's permeable we
this is a perennial issue you know you
have you have you don't have enough
Force to secure the whole city so
frankly the ukrainians might be able to
even break through and do some resuppies
but I have a feeling that portion of the
city could really at this point hold out
for weeks and months okay coming back to
the the point you made about resupply
for those ukrainians courses let's talk
about what they've been supplied with
and who's that's coming from if we take
first of all a look at Europe we know
that Europe has has implemented tough
sanctions on Russia that it has applied
uh military aid and also economic aid
there has however been a lot of
criticism of Germany namely on the
hesitation to send heavy weapons but
also to issue an embargo on Russian oil
and gas can you from the perspective of
Germany understand where that reluctance
is coming from there's a long kind of
pacifist streak uh or since the end of
World War II that is is ingrained in in
uh Germany and there's also kind of a um
a lot of empathy for the Russian
perspective uh that's that again carries
over from World War II based on the the
perception that Russia is the inheritor
of the Soviet Union and uh Germany
inflicted massive harm on Russia so I in
the early times in the early uh time
frame it was it was
reasonable to be empathetic but at this
point frankly
Germany's uh position is is irrational
uh it's clearly a um now a question of
whether Germany wishes to preserve the
the Western liberal order and what
wishes to uh uh support democracies
in an onslaught from authoritarianism
and to me it's now uh past the point of
you know being understanding for
Germany's reluctance it's it's the point
where it seems absurd that Germany is
not doing enough either to impose costs
on Russia for for uh for this uh War to
reduce Russia's material support its
budgetary uh income from oil and gas
trade of course there's now the
discussion about winding down oil trade
by the end of 2022 that's a long time
away and frankly I could see the the
German government reversing course if
they see any Lifeline like if there's a
glimmer of hope I could easily see this
Administration unfortunately reversing
course on that so it could end up being
an empty promise on that note also and
then on the military front I'm pretty
pretty uh sad to see the rest of uh
Europe coming together uh with the
show's support for Ukraine for democracy
for preserving the Western liberal order
for pushing back on fascism this newest
Incarnation and fascism emanating from
Russia in Germany playing the leader of
Europe
playing such a reluctant role it is uh
it is it is in opposition to to I think
the German people's will and and frankly
Germany's values uh that the government
is is now
um
stymied or uh I can't seem to piece
together a coherent strategy moving
forward if we listen to what the German
government government has said on a
Russian oil and gas embargo it has said
that it would damage the German economy
inflict such damage on the German
economy that it would no longer be able
to confront President Putin from a
position of strength A and B that it
would perhaps lose some of the broad
support that there is in the German
society as you've said yourself and that
that is a reason to avoid a complete
Russian oil and gas embarker what do you
think of that I got to tell you that's
pretty absurd and a pretty thin uh what
we call a straw man argument uh you know
in fact
Germany much uh Germany hasn't uh hasn't
absorbed hardly any of the costs right
now the costs are being absorbed by
Ukraine that's uh that's defending
German values European values defending
democracy for the whole world absorbing
an enormous cost and for the German
government to kind of sidestep its
obligations as a leader is shockingly
bad judgment the other thing that I
think we should recognize is that there
should be a shared burden if not shared
with uh with
um Ukraine it should be shared with
Europe and Eastern Europe is absorbing
enormous amount of of the shock here
they're absorbing you know millions of
refugees they're absorbing enormous
economic costs why is it that Germany
thinks that it could sidestep the cost
it is
I I I it's hard to rationalize the
perspective that the the German uh
people in the German government are not
going to absorb some of the cost for a
crisis situation that we're in a state
of a cold war between the west and and
Russia and uh we're trying to avoid a
hot War let's pick up on the
absorbing some of the there because we
saw President Biden announcing another
800 dollars
military and economic assistance for
Ukraine as you know uh that brings I
think the total that the U.S has uh
allocated for Ukraine to 3.4 billion
dollars and you say it's not enough what
more needs to be done the budgets for
for DOD are so vast and for the US
government so vast that it seems
impressive that these no these resources
coming through seem like a lot but
actually it's not it's not a significant
uh uh portion of the US budget or the
defense budget uh not at this point not
especially if you measure it against the
the yardstick of the resources poured
into Afghanistan you know we're talking
about tens of billions of dollars not
three billion dollars so that it's it's
you need to have contacts then you need
to have a frame of reference it is not
that large an amount and we're still
well shy of what I've called for uh you
know in in some of the things I've
written which is a
lend lease program
where all the equipment that Ukraine
needs to prosecute this war could be
retained uh you know on NATO territory
in the east in Poland in Romania in
Slovakia and in warehouses where Ukraine
could draw on on this equipment as
needed not you know make a request and
then let it go through bureaucratic
channels that could take weeks and then
it takes another several weeks to
transport it but literally have
everything pre-positioned there because
we as military planners understand
what's going on we could foresee the
kinds of needs that they need that
should all be there it should be ready
for the ukrainians to draw as necessary
that's what alembly's program uh you
know functional lend lease program would
look like some of the reluctance from
the West to engage more is because of a
fear of being drawn into a bigger
conflict do you understand the concerns
from NATO of the fear of a possible
nuclear war for example because you've
said that you believe Russia has no
interest in a nuclear war they have an
interest in messaging a nuclear war but
NATO's saying we don't know that for
sure that's kind of again another straw
man argument there's nothing to on the
balance when when you when we say
something like that it's a falling prey
to kind of nuclear blackmail and
following pray to kind of almost Primal
fears of uh worst case scenarios in
reality if we start to parse out the
logic of uh how something like this
could unfold it seems uh patently absurd
that the Russians that are looking to
aggrandize uh Putin is looking to
aggrandize Russia expand Russian power
is willing to in the same breath somehow
risk a nuclear Armageddon mutually
assure destruction those two don't kind
of Jive right if I could just jump in
that would mean that you believe that
President Putin is acting is a rational
actor he is a rational actor he's a
rational actor that's been incurred
urged by the West in a lot of ways he's
been a rational actor that's been in
power for 22 years and through multiple
administrations that have looked the
other way as he uh transgressed
increasingly whether that's domestically
in under Democratic movements crushing
business interests and crushing what he
thought was an oligarchy that was
involved in Russian politics it was uh
the Chechen wars were it was uh you know
inhuman brutality uh on a smaller scale
than we're seeing now but the same
template in Syria uh in uh 2014 when
they started this war against Ukraine
these are things that we should have
taken more concerted actions against but
we thought it was limited we thought
that you know this is where it ends this
is as bad it's gonna get that is a great
deal of wishful thinking about who
Vladimir Putin was and uh what how far
he's willing to go instead what we did
was we sent signals that he could get
away with it he can push further now
this was a huge enormous miscalculation
on this part he fundamentally
misunderstood who the Ukrainian people
were he misunderstood who the German
people were he misunderstood who the
American people were and that you know
we would we we had wishful thinking
about kind of what amounted to smaller
contingencies but when when uh when it
really mattered when the stakes were
high we were going to come together
and defend our values I do have to ask
you before we let you go as we mentioned
you were instrumental in well what
eventually led to president Trump's
impeachment
imagine in 2024 another Trump presidency
how could Europe and NATO prepare then
for that scenario
far-fetched to believe that Donald Trump
can return to the presidency and the way
I do this is I you know I look at the
the
the 2020 election results he lost by
seven seven million votes significant
margin after January 6th he lost tens of
millions of people that were you know
that were disgusted by him uh
nurturing an attack on the Capitol
Building since then he's continued to to
uh my cheerlead and bandwagon for the
Vladimir Putin losing Millions more so
his short his uh slice of the pie has
continued to shrink now he might be very
well the kind of the Republican nominee
but I don't see a path to victory for
him to uh uh to the general elections I
think regardless
um you know I guess in this uh hyper uh
counterfactual scenario I think
um I think as president macron is to a
certain extent indicated uh there is an
opportunity for Europe to
take a leadership role and um in terms
of uh global stability and protecting
democracies and I think I would like to
see Germany play uh you know the
partnership is unequal there too Germany
provides the economic resources to a
certain extent France provides the kind
of the the the the division I would like
to see a shared burden uh uh where both
sides contribute kind of um both to the
economic outputs but also to the to the
vision and I'd like to see Germany take
a leading role also in the direction of
Europe
not just in the financial structures
we'll leave it there thank you so much
lieutenant colonel vinman